this is one of the most violent and
ruthless pirates in all of one piece a
man who took out one of the four
emperors and exchanged blows with two
more this is someone who after two years
in the new world has lost an arm but
gained enormous power in return
while luffy is going to face the
mysterious and destructive powers of
blackbeard as his biggest fight in the
story yet he is bound to take down his
foil
shanks and according to it
himself the true reason that he wants to
take down shanks is not related to
losing his arm equipped with the
frightening combination of both a
devastating and fully awakened devil
fruit and the will of a conqueror he
doesn't show any mercy to his enemies
like this one here who he had crucified
and disposed of as he's willing to do
literally anything even the most
unthinkable things to get a step closer
to his ultimate goal the throne of the
pirate worlds
but then there's also this the worries
and love for inakama growing closer and
fighting side by side with luffy until
we actually see him cheering for luffy
and trusting in his powers so how do
these two radically different traits
come together in the same person who is
this man that shares so many
similarities with the most mysterious
and powerful characters in one piece his
red hair his missing arm the scars over
his eyes and what is his actual purpose
as luffy's arguably most evil ally in
the story this gruesome depiction here
is an illustration of something that
actually happened because captain
eustace's kit and his character are
inspired by the real-life pirates used
as the monk and captain william kitts
the latter was infamous for his cruelty
william kidd was also the son of another
famous pirate captain john kitts and who
knew this elderly gentleman with a very
unhealthy complexion is actually the
infamous captain john a former member of
the rock's pirates and revived by
gekkomoria here and even though
admittedly kit looks a lot more like
another certain redhead pirate it has
been speculated that this guy right here
might be a much more likely candidate
for kid's father that he never has and i
think this also shows in his devil fruit
powers while luffy is creative flexible
and funny just like his rubbery sun god
devil fruit kid's cold iron heart and
edgy nature is wonderfully embodied in
his jikijiki fruit that not only looks
absolutely fire but is also ridiculously
powerful now sadly we didn't get to see
much of kids fighting before onigashima
especially this moment right here where
he was ambushed by kaido but i wish we'd
get to see that these panels during
onigashima however do show us how his
fruit truly works in its pure and
awakened form and so i truly feel that
atira oda the author of one piece has
fully made up for this this year for
example is a technique called punk clash
one of kids strongest abilities turning
big mom into such a strong magnet that
even giant steel beams from the castle
wall crushed into her and while in his
base form kit himself is magnetic his
awakening allows him to assign magnetism
to areas and objects that he touches in
other words an extremely overpowered
ability as i think big mom's defeat at
kids in law's hands more than clearly
proves i think when eustace's kid
introduced himself to us for the very
first time in the story overseeing the
terrible human auction on sabaodi he
also gave us the most important piece of
information about himself as he watches
nobles and other people with money and
influence enter the auction house to buy
people like property he tells us exactly
what he thinks about all that world
nobles slaves human shops against the
purity of the so-called nobles the
villains of the world look positively
humane in comparison it's because the
world's in the hands of such scum like
these that it's all broken i mean we're
not the nicest of guys but at least
we're honest about it kid is very much
aware that he's not exactly
on the jolly side of piracy like luffy
is he knows very well that the things he
does are terrible however if he sees
himself down here on the morrow ladder
the people who actually rule this world
like the celestial dragons are not only
five levels below him but also
responsible for people like him to
become this twisted and cruel in the
first place and i believe that this is
also how we tend to see kit as well as a
much darker version of luffy who's
willing to do messed up things very
extremely messed up things but at the
same time it seems pretty clear that he
also is fighting for a world without the
government or at least a world where he
can be free from people like the
government just like luffy and that's
exactly the main point of his character
what i find beyond interesting is that
used as kit doesn't only play the
contrasting character for one but two
people in the story this is kid's
gigantic magnetic arm next to luffy's
gear third here are luffy and kit having
a competition about literally anything
in udon prison who can carry the most
who can eat the most who can make
queen's eyes bulge the most and this is
kid just like luffy beaten by kaido in a
cell but refusing to give up both of
them hate nothing more than losing both
on saba odi and on wano we see luffy and
kids storming on a hat with la trying to
reign them in and protect their bags
from any kind of threats and so not for
nothing has kid always been portrayed as
the straw hat's number one rival among
the supernova for becoming king of the
pirates that's all nice and good but
what then is the deal with him and
shanks oh boy i left you on the
cliffhanger there on purpose because
first we need to talk about the
delicious sponsor of today's video box
suit boxu is a monthly snack box
subscription service that delivers
original assortments of premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings directly from
here in japan to wherever you may live
every box has a unique theme and so this
month box is celebrating its sixth
anniversary with the boksu tanjobi box
which if you are nihongo jouzu literally
means boxu birthday box the best thing
about beside how good all this stuff
tastes is that they collaborate with
traditional japanese family
manufacturers that actually make all
these snacks and candies advice
particularly on the strawberry truffles
mochi from nigata prefecture and also on
these green tea chocolate coated azuki
beans from yamagata so this is the
perfect opportunity to experience some
great authentic japanese food if you
want to try it out for yourself go get
your own box of snack box and get 15 of
your first order using my code or horror
15 and the link in the description below
a very popular saying that you might
have come across somewhere before is
that kit is luffy without the plot armor
and even though i really don't like that
term because plot armor is basically
just plot i do agree with the idea
behind this you see on the plus side kit
is luffy but not bound to the classic
moral standards of a shonen hero yes he
loves and trusts his crew just like
luffy but towards literally anyone else
he's just straight out cruel and he can
use any means possible to get stronger
and achieve the very same dream as luffy
without oda sensei having to worry at
all about the message that this might
send to his core audience on the
downside however not being luffy also
means that kit doesn't share his unique
ability to create allies wherever he
goes that help him become stronger
instead of being trained by rayleigh for
two years in a row he directly marches
into the new world where he almost loses
his life to shanks oh yeah shanks
missing arm scar over the eye red hair
really no coincidence because this is
the second character that kit is a
direct foil to think about it shank
sacrificed an arm to inspire luffy to
become a pirate while taking an arm from
kids who for some mysterious reason is
absolutely obsessed with him while
shanks really doesn't mind having just
one arm kit clearly feels the strong
need to replace it with his devil fruit
powers though i do honestly on a
personal level fully understand that the
main point of comparison however between
this yonko and this supernova however is
how they deal with the people who laugh
at them and doubt them as you well know
in chapter 1 of the story just after
luffy has eaten his mythical zone devil
fruit shanks calmly takes a beating by
higuma and his mountain bandits
something that luffy then later on
coolly imitates on jaya with bellamy in
fact if you're curious why that was such
a big deal in the first place i made a
whole video about just that scene with
bellamy and blackbeard the point is kid
behaves well
just like a kid just like kid luffy he
punishes and kills those who dare to
laugh at his dreams whereas luffy and
shanks pity those without any dreams and
don't see them as worthy opponents in
the first place and so in other words
kid quite literally to his name needs to
grow up which as we will see in a second
he has really been doing during the wano
arc now i just recently bought the 14th
volume of the official one piece
magazine fittingly enough titled rivals
by the way that had a massive character
discussion section about kit that helped
me a lot with this analysis honestly
finally all that japanese study coming
in handy i guess the main theme of kit
and his crew is literally that of rebels
of being anti-establishment if he wants
kit obviously has a strong steampunk
heavy metal sort of theme going on just
look at his apac punk rotten and those
goggles in particular and i mean the
ship he's sailing on is just awesome i
mean it's by far my favorite design in
the entire story it's called the
victoria punk and has this giant skull
of whatever animal that is at its bow
and funnily enough apart from kid and
his childhood friend killer the name of
every single one of his crew members is
based on famous rock bands or any other
music related terms heat who can
literally breathe fire is based on this
swedish band this is wire named after
the english rock bands that also house
boogie and my two favorite nakama hip
and hop who i do think have the most
awesome and also most lazy names in all
of one piece at the same time the second
and much more hidden theme in the crew
is something i would never have guessed
though honestly the kid pirates are also
hippies look at this these are killer's
pants and this is heat's outfit can't
really unsee it once you know can you
and to me it makes a really good job at
reflecting these two sides of kit and
his crew the rough and edgy together
with this sort of kind of fun and kind
and peaceful side of him a fun little
story i also discussed while looking
through this is that kid and killer are
not only best childhood friends from the
south blue but that they also had the
same childhood crush that spilled a bow
of udon over herself at some point which
is why now it is both of their least
favorite foods which is a hilarious
little pun order sensor has made because
both kit and killer were held captive in
udon prison but i also think that it
once again hints at kids kinder and more
caring nature as well i kinda
sidetracked there for a second but i'm
convinced that we got all of these
little details because they help
illustrate who kid truly is as a
character kid clearly has suffered
through a lot of trauma and pain
throughout his life this for example is
him as a kid but kid kid if you want so
and clearly growing up in a harsh
environment according to oda sensei
kit's most important principle in life
is having no concern for anyone but his
nakama in other words for those he
trusts kit would do anything something
he proves to us with his reaction when
he finds out that killer has been forced
to eat a smile devil fruit however it's
also really obvious that it is really
hard for him to actually build trust
with others in the first place which of
course really hits home though one time
we see him begrudgingly form an alliance
with a poo and hawkins only to be
betrayed like five minutes later
literally so when you look at this kid
at the beginning of wano angry
distrusting versus this kid right here
thrilled with the joy of battle and
trusting in luffy to take down kaido one
versus one damn girl what an emotional
glow up i mean in the beginning he only
joins the raid because he wants revenge
on kaido kind of tagging along while
still doing his own thing like i'm not
part of this alliance but i guess you
will lose without me so i'll come strong
tsundere vibes from kit right there i
think spending time with luffy and udon
definitely was the basis for him even
tagging along in the first place but he
was still going to be the one who takes
down kaido this here however is the very
first major change of character he shows
us as he sees zorro heroically risking
his own life for everyone else on the
roof as kid very well understands that
is not something that a traitor would
actually do and so over the course of
the fight kid sees the true nature of
luffy zorro and law and while he does
keep arguing with all of them a lot he
more and more integrates as part of the
team he counts on law to have his back
and starts coordinating his attacks with
him and luffy and ultimately when big
mom finally reappears he focuses on
separating the qiyonko now fully
believing in luffy and acknowledging his
true powers i honestly think it's also
more than likely that kid might
accompany luffy to this island where
shanks is most likely waiting and where
he will finally be able to confront him
because elbaf has been foreshadowed as
the next major arc in the story and so
if you want to know all the crazy events
that might await kid and luffy on the
island of the giants you really should
watch this video here next and see what
the story could have in store for them i
really hope you enjoyed this video and i
hope to see you in the next one thanks
for watching